do you guys like a guy that looks to you
to make decisions
i would say
like what do you mean like what kind of
decisions um just like if there's a big
decision you have to make in your
household and instead like he doesn't
like he looks to you to make it instead
of making it himself
um
it's an interesting scenario i don't
think i've been in that scenario before
i've never been on that scene
give us give us an actual realistic
scenario that would happen um a
realistic scenario um you have to decide
what
where you're going to move or what like
just a pulpit or something yeah a house
you're going to buy that's a big
decision
i don't think i would mind it at all
honestly
but i mean i also like would like his
opinion i guess because i don't want to
like move us all in one place and then
have him resent me for doing that what
about what about like dates when he asks
you like to plan the date
i mean i don't mind that i look like
really
you don't like that no not at all i'm
like a foodie so i'm like i will huh
your partner
you know
tell us
i know i know i
um
you know us guys like we're not really
that creative now 2020 is more or less
like oh let's get some food and watch a
movie that's us or like you go good stop
pause rewind it again i said i was first
date no no like yeah yeah i felt like
thursday i know it's gotta be a little
bit of fun like go top most people like
top golf something i got active right
but for the most part it's a dinner
movie dinner
unless you've been dating for a long
long time yeah because then you just sit
there not talking
he gets it he gets it
come forward sorry hello
i'm getting out right now i'm sorry you
should be shoot that's that's uh no
don't do that um and as i was saying to
you it was a first date it was a first
date and a guy said to you hey
let's meet up
you choose you it's all in your hands so
you pick it yeah you check the time you
use a date you pay for it okay i mean i
respect that he's like putting like the
control in my hands but i want the
controller but i find it more attractive
when he's taken the control himself
so if he's like okay
oh let's go on a date i'll make a
reservation somewhere then i'm like oh
that's attractive because he's making
plans like i'm not pushing him to do
anything if he's putting the control in
my hand it sends a different message i
would say like like when they do plan it
out it makes it seem like they are
really interested in yes and they like
want it more you know because then
they're like okay let's do this isn't
this mess and they like have a mind
already like have a thing in their mind
like they're like thinking about what's
going to happen and with the equality of
dating in the way men approach like
dating
and dating i don't think there is
because
men don't have that many options we all
know like men will swipe right and all
women on tinder and then get a few
matches and it's kind of the opposite
for women
yeah like women don't have to swipe that
often but we'll get matches that kind of
thing and just the way that men approach
women and get dates i feel like because
it's like formulated in that way that
men's kind of approaching the woman the
man is approaching the woman that they
should kind of organize the day like it
doesn't make sense to change that
when it's out that way so straight i'm
going to ask the question so sorry for
you go ahead
um so
just a quick yes or no and then later
second question
do you feel that there should be i don't
answer that question so should there be
gender roles in a relationship yes or no
um i think some gender roles are good no
no no yes or no yes or no just
how traditional gender roles should they
exist do i not get asked the questions
yes
yes but not like everything you know
like not like the old traditional but i
would say like some of them still i
think there's a bit of flexibility
within the gender roles yeah but i do
think that there's a positive side to it
so what about equality then
because
and i want to pause before you answer i
want to say something about it okay
equality says everything's equal right
gender roles existed when things weren't
equal
yeah i'll say do you have two
things uh
are not they can't work together
you think they're not mutually exclusive
i don't think that's true anymore i do
think there's gender roles and equality
and do you think you can just do
bring what you can bring to the table
and this other person brings what they
can bring to the table and you kind of
match that and you kind of
if i do the cooking you can do the
cleaning or that kind of thing where you
both work together as a team at the end
result is equality that you both feel
like everyone's committed to the
relationship so it's not that i'm doing
more tasks than you it's more like i'm
helping you you're helping me and you
feel like it's working so okay no would
you say like there are generals they're
just not as restricted as before then i
think there are gender roles and i don't
think there's a problem with that yeah
but i don't think they're more flexible
so you can choose who has the gender
role
like who's going to be the person in the
house like the house man or housewoman
and then they'll have their roles within
that the roles of the house person who's
staying at home it's not like just the
woman or just the man for example so
where i kind of describe that is this
you would expect as women i i'm i'm
gonna make an assumption you could have
come wrong but i i assume that you'd
expect that man pays you especially the
first couple of dates you spend time
with us um i mean not fully i mean so
like i just like went to paris and i was
like
oh like let me you know for a while but
i guess so okay you're right you're
right
he you went out for dinner you planned
it he made you ask for you to plan it
and he expected you to pay for the
drinks and dinner whatever you did in
the first day how would you have felt at
the time would you have seen him again
probably not like that
that is bad you're gonna date on a guy
you've met a guy online or wherever and
he stopped numbers you talking for a
while he goes hey let's meet up he says
you plan it you put a date you put a
time you pay for it
how do you feel i
i wouldn't feel positive towards it
because what's the point of me like
dating i don't know like having someone
being in a relationship someone like
you're supposed to benefit from that
and if i'm making my own trick
you know what i'm saying
our company wow that's the most generic
answer you can ever get oh she gets me
like if you're an independent woman and
you you're financially stable you've got
a job you've got everything you need in
life why do i need to pay for a date for
a man
but i mean okay but you because you said
that if he was to ask me on a date i
would say if you're asking me on a date
then you want to take me on one so you
should be paying
like if they're dating someone you're
like oh let's go out let's have a first
date there's a so a woman meets a guy in
a bar chats him out guts his number
talks to him i think this happens more
than you think i think women push like a
kind of a catalyst for most
relationships like oh like we should
meet up they push things in that
direction men are sometimes a bit slow
it's like okay i directly want to go on
a date they might talk for ages if a
woman doesn't intervene but regardless
like that wasn't the point of the thing
it wasn't like do women ask men on date
it's the point was he pays when men ask
women on date
like why
yeah pay for the date so reason reason
was questions because
this
might as well in my opinion that the two
things that you can't have gender
equality but then expect traditional
outcomes
i don't think the institutional outcome
is that we are still a date we pay for a
day yeah but i mean okay but if women
were supposed to like were to ask you on
the date
no
i said if women were to were to ask you
on a date you don't
okay but that's not the point here
if you were to no no no no
yeah and then
i mean i don't think they would they
would pay for the date weren't they
this is like a cultural thing i think
it's more about like culture than to do
with like gender equality so sometimes
we have traditions that just cultured
make sense for western culture that's
kind of like the gentleman kind of
stereotype just doing that no you're
going that extra mile for us
i can't i'll say a gentleman couldn't
exist in today's society if you have
equality it wouldn't interfere with
chivalry existed in a time when men
out earned women we might like to work
we had to do all right so there were
things that women had to do for women
for to be chivalrous if you're all equal
then why am i cheating especially why
would you be more special it's
culturally equal
if we're equal
it's a grand gesture it's not going to
open a door for debbie for dobby dobby
debbie if we're in a bed that's cool
to come out the car you can be a
gentleman to a man like there's no like
there's nothing
no
no
no it does not
okay you've got two bags of shopping and
a guy opens the door for you like for
another guy
do you appreciate the chivalry i want to
know
this is where the difference is right
it's like look it's one thing you're
like cool i'm not saying like yeah if
i'm walking outside like
my hands are full yeah and someone opens
the door like a guy who was walking past
me that's that's like helpful i wouldn't
consider anything like that but i
wouldn't expect a man to be like yeah
yeah
open the door for me and be like yeah
sit down close it for me move back
around like where we going like no i
would never we're in the car and i come
around to open the door for you to let
you in the car
not you're like a man invented the
revolving door what a man invented the
revolving door because he didn't want to
open doors for women maybe thank you
thank you
thank
you he took her personally
why'd you think we would enter the
rolls-royce man it opened the door
and closes them say that again
rolls-royce
automatically
okay i think we're going to have a
tangent so no he actually has a decent
point because a common complaint i hear
from matt is that women want equality
but only when it benefits us
and so this is kind of a situation where
like yeah we want the date
yeah we want to be courted yeah but
at the cost yeah but like isn't that
human nature to try and get as much as
you can for as little
effort as possible yeah
you work the best job or like
that earns the most money maybe not
because it's like
nourishing for your mind you just do
what you can do that gives you the best
reward and i think that comes for dating
and equality as well